you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme temperatures of 40
degrees will become the norm
a warning that the uk is heating up fast
as last year is the third hottest on
record
ground zero in the climate crisis the
arctic is warming three times faster
than anywhere else on the planet
as it experiences never before events
and extreme weather around the world
with wildfires in greece
lebanon and turkey floods in bangladesh
and snow in parts of brazil for the
first time in
65 years
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and it is a day of
particularly stark warnings about those
changes to our world
we're going to start here in the uk
where we have a clearer picture
of just how quickly the climate is
warming
the met office says the country is
already experiencing
extreme weather because of climate
change and we could regularly see summer
temperatures
above 40 degrees celsius even
if global heating is limited to an
average
of one and a half degrees there's clear
evidence the uk
is quickly getting hotter wetter and
sunnier
let's have a look now last year was the
third hottest since records began
10 of the warmest years have all come
since 2002
and the last 30 years have been 0.9
degrees warmer
than the preceding 30 a trend evident
across all months
and all parts of the uk but the greatest
warming has been across the east
midlands
and east anglia where average annual
temperatures have increased by more than
one degrees celsius that's in line with
projections
showing greater warming in the south of
england now the areas with the least
warming
are around western coastal fringes and
parts of northern ireland and scotland
rainfall though has increased as well
over the last three decades
the uk has been six percent wetter on
average
than the three decades before and six
of the ten wettest years have occurred
since
1998. 2020 was the fifth
wettest on record our climate
correspondent
hannah thomas peter reports avon mouth
on the river seven
flooding is a part of life here but it's
getting worse
that's why the government's chosen this
place to announce how it's going to
spend
billions of pounds on flood protection
schemes across the country this is to
better protect our
homes our communities our businesses
and make us more resilient to climate
change we know we're going to get more
extreme weather events
we need to be prepared for them despite
the influx of cash eventually hard
decisions will have to be made
about who and what is protected from the
rising water
roughly one in every five
households is at risk of flooding there
may come a time in the future
where as part of that building back
better we need to consider whether we
move to better places where the risk
of flooding is reduced
global warming is reshaping our world in
other ways too
in terms of sheer destructive power rain
and flooding
often grabs the headlines in the uk but
climate change is also
driving up our temperatures at the met
office headquarters
in exeter they've been tracking some
worrying patterns
this is where operational meteorologists
senior climate scientist mike kenden
has just written a report revealing that
2020 was the first year since records
began
to rank in the top 10 for heat rainfall
and sunshine climate change isn't just
something that's going to happen in the
future
climate change is something that is
happening now we see that very clearly
in our observations
as a scientist i'm worried that looking
at his observations
you know i'm a dad i worry about the
future
for my children the royal meteorological
society has warned that even a small
increase in global warming
could mean british summertime
temperatures reaching 40 degrees
in this country the race to adapt to the
effects of climate change
has only just begun hannah thomas peter
sky news aven mouth well there's also a
warning the arctic is warming
three times faster than anywhere else on
earth
making it ground zero for the climate
crisis
scientists say the area is experiencing
never before events that threaten us all
because what happens in the arctic
drives climate change
around the world let's take a closer
look at the figures
average temperatures in the arctic have
increased by 0.81 degrees
per decade over the last 30 years more
than three times the global
average which is 0.23 degrees celsius
there's also concerns that sea level
rises created by melting
ice sheets in the region would dwarf any
previous warnings
the greenland ice sheet alone for
instance
could raise global sea levels by seven
and a half meters
meanwhile the warm weather conditions
that would lead to the thawing of
permafrost
in the far north are already occurring
75
years ahead of predictions that research
is by the climate crisis advisory group
which says the window of time to repair
the climate is closing fast
so david king is the group's chair
the analysis is showing that even by
mid-century
if we take southeast asia as a region of
the world where sea level rises
due to melting ice in on greenland due
to melting ice elsewhere on the planet
raising sea levels globally we
are going to see southeast asia maybe a
hundred million maybe
300 million refugees because regions of
that world will be
underwater too regularly well in a
moment we'll look at the political
implications
but first to our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter
hannah a day of serious warnings just
how significant is this
i think what you're seeing from the
scientific community is that we are
increasingly stepping towards the
unknown and there is a sense of panic
about that because it's hard to control
outcomes that you can't model
or predict particularly on the uk side
we've had this very serious report from
the met office saying that climate
change is already here
an impact in the united kingdom
particularly when it comes to
extreme rainfall and extreme heat and
that more is much likely to come and
experts have already said today
that they're not sure that our critical
infrastructure our roads our bridges our
rail lines our hospitals and so on
are built to withstand what is to come
and then
more globally of course we've had this
very serious report from
sir david king former chief scientific
adviser to the government
uh and he has said uh very clearly that
the arctic is in
is in real trouble is uh warming and the
ice is melting much
faster than was predicted and that can
in turn
mess with all kinds of uh systems that
are supposed to regulate the planet like
for example
uh the jet stream trapping extreme heat
events and extreme
storms in place for longer and
increasing the potential damage
the scientific community is stepping up
its urgency
as stepping up its calls for action and
just
hoping that the politicians and world
leaders will listen
hannah thank you appreciate your
analysis well there is more focus than
ever on what global leaders can do to
tackle the climate crisis we face
the united states special presidential
envoy for climate is in london
and spoke with former uk prime minister
tony blair a little earlier
glasgow is the last best hope to avoid
the worst consequences
and to avoid the planet changing in ways
that are even hard to predict
i mean as as the himalayas glaciers are
melting
arctic is melding four times faster than
it was 10 years ago
and more than anywhere else the greatest
warming on the planet
is in the arctic when the scientists and
the experts are telling you
these are the consequences if you don't
do x
y or z the the sort of rule of
prudence governs the notion that you
ought to be ahead of the curve on those
things
well let's cross now to our chief
political correspondent john craig
john it's been a day of extraordinary
warnings from
scientists and indeed from john kerry
but it's just
less than 100 days now until the uk
hosts
the global climate change conference cop
26 is there any sign that global leaders
and politicians are going to step up
and rise to the occasion well not for
the first time the
british government is likely to be
accused of mixed messages now
when he appeared a few weeks ago before
the liaison
committee of senior mps in the commons
uh the prime minister was quizzed on his
uh
climate change and cop 26 strategy he
said he would
unveil that before the summit which
takes place
in glasgow but from the prime minister
uh came a pretty uh firm warning that he
won't allow
domestic bills to go up to pay for
greener energy
he said we can't have a situation in
which ordinary homeowners are suddenly
faced with an unexpected and
unreasonable cost it's got to be a
solution that's affordable
works for people at the moment the
prices of the greener energy
are too high he said the government was
determined to keep the bills low
that was a priority and yet from the
environment secretary
george eustis who has today unveiled
what the government calls
a flood and coastal erosion investment
plan to tackle
uh flooding he's pledged to tackle
climate change to cope with flooding
he's uh talked about how
climate change means a more extreme
weather a higher risk of flooding events
and coastal
erosion so the government is determined
to tackle the
climate change in that respect and yet
the prime minister is insisting
he won't allow domestic bills to go up
to tackle climate change
very interesting indeed john thank you
and we're tracking key climate change
measures on our data dashboard you can
find that on the sky news app
and on the web at skynews.com forward
slash climate
well there may be warnings of more
extreme weather to come in the uk
but there are devastating examples
happening around the world right now as
well
from wildfires in turkey greece and
lebanon to floods in bangladesh
and even snow in a part of brazil for
the first time
in 65 years
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in today's other climate news the met
office says the first named storm of the
summer
will hit the uk tonight forecasters are
predicting
storm evert will bring unseasonably
strong winds and heavy rain to southern
parts of the country
with winds of up to 75 miles per hour
expected
an amber warning has been issued for
cornwall and the silly isles
and the uk's first ever bison rangers
have been selected to help introduce the
animals into the country
tom gibbs and donovan wright were picked
from more than a thousand
applicants from around the world to look
after the herd
the four european bison will live in
lean woods
an ancient woodland in kent to help
restore the natural habitat
of the area well we've talked a lot
today about the threat from global
heating and how climate change is
changing our world
right now but what can we do to reduce
our impact
and slow the process well someone who
knows more about this is bethany watson
an apprentice at bae systems a company
that works with fuel change a platform
for young people to get involved with
climate action
projects bethany thank you very much
indeed for joining us
why was it important to you to work for
a company that has
these sorts of climate change issues
that you can work on and what are you
focusing on at the moment it was
especially important for me to work for
a company like be systems
um who has climate change and at the
forefront
of their minds all the time and they
widely encourage their apprentices
to get involved with things like fuel
change and so myself and a team
of seven other apprentices enjoying the
first round of fuel change last year
and and we worked with multiple
different corporations
in order to try and solve their in
climate change issues
and so we came up with an initiative
that would
take scap material and especially
scrap material from um decommissioned
aircrafts that are sitting in plain
graveyards
and turn that material into small
vertical wind turbines that we
put on in the sides of roads and on top
of buildings
and so that we're creating something
that is green and it's also producing
green energy
and so there was many teams that were
involved with this initiative
and and they were all trying to solve
issues like this and so it was
especially important
and for us to you know try and make
change
as individuals and as teams well bethany
thank you very much indeed for joining
us today we are keen to hear some
positive news when it comes to climate
change thank you very much indeed
well that's everything from us for today
next time we'll be looking at how
olympic athletes will have to adapt to
rising
global temperatures you can find out
more about that tomorrow here
on the daily climate show see you then
you